what is a real man rich
[Laughter]
what is a man it is a biological male
that is an adult
in the war on masculinity what is a real
man
well if you well if you ask
it depends what side you ask right I
mean if you ask the side that's waging
the war on masculinity they're going to
tell you that
anything that is conventionally
masculine is potentially or is toxic
isn't it
but it's funny isn't it though that if
there's a war or there's a fire or
there's policing that's required or you
need something a guy that's big and
strong that they call a conventionally
masculine man to come and deal with
those things to put out the fires to
deal with the bad guys to go to the wars
and you know deal with the evil in the
world but anytime we have peace and calm
in society if you don't like something
or the way that it's going for you it's
very easy to say that guy over there
he's toxic masculinity please you know
don't scare me I feel
very uncomfortable in your presence
um there is a there is a war on
masculinity today it's it's a it's a
feature it's a function of feminism
continuing into an area that looks like
a Supremacy movement to me I don't think
there's any area I mean you could ask
anybody whether it's a woman or a
visible minority you know what what are
your disadvantages in life today you
know what what is it that that white
person over there can do that or that
white male over there can do that you
can't do as a woman or as a woman of
color for example
and they really struggle to find things
don't they
so I don't think there's any difference
in the world today as far as
inequalities especially in modern
Western worlds some people would even
argue that the advantages of tilted in
the favor of women you know at this
stage especially in areas like family
law right uh if you don't believe me ask
anybody that's been divorced in a
western country and find out how fairly
the father gets treated versus the
mother there is a strong inequality that
plays in the mother's favor so it seems
like it's gotten the point where it's
now moving into a position of a
Supremacy movement where it's looking
for the subjugation and the servitude of
men and the continuous apologies of men
we see this all the time on mainstream
media and on uh all these other
different platforms where you know men
are are apologizing or kissing the feet
of of people for sins that don't even
exist anymore
do you think this is because we've had
two such a good amount of time decades
maybe of good times and you know the
whole adage Good Times creates weak
people
um and weak people create hard times and
hard times create strong people do you
think that's part of it do you think
lockdown was part of it what are your
thoughts on why we are where we're at
well
I don't think it's any question that we
live in a very peaceful time and human
beings are not very peaceful as a
species are we I've seen I've seen
plotted infographics uh over tens of
thousands of years that have documented
conflict and Wars throughout history
um and if you can just picture
they scream with a bunch of pepper dots
off to the left and in recent time off
to the right there's a lot fewer of them
or if they do appear they're slightly
larger like you'd see a world war one or
a world World War II but throughout
history we've we really like Wars you
know as a species and we've been at
conflict pretty much throughout history
we live in a very calm time uh we have
easy access to plentiful calories going
to any store we have easy access to
transport anywhere in the world we have
easy access to health care you know in
most places in the world so safe safe
clean water you know you don't have to
worry about turning on your faucet and
making yourself a cup of coffee or a cup
of tea and getting uh some kind of
intestinal disease we live in very clean
and safe times and that and that gives
people other things to do with their
times and unfortunately when
you've been dealing with Decades of the
softening of society the weakening of
the western male you know if you will
and the encouragement of women to become
more like men like we live in a time now
where women are are told that they don't
need a man they can do anything a man
can do if not better and men are
incompetent they're bumbling fools and
idiots I mean if you watch any of the
Hollywood shows or sitcoms that I did
Growing Up
um
Family Ties The Cosby Show Home
Improvement the father in the show was
always portrayed as a bumbling in
the and the mother was a savior of the
household she was a hero
um we're just at that place in time
where I think that once you see all
these things and you start to see the
code in The Matrix and you understand
what's going on it's it's a slow
Progressive decade upon decade process
of the softening and the weakening of
strong Western males I think the
lockdown was a nice test of all that
they wanted to see how far they could go
clearly because in hindsight now that
we've seen most of the evidence
um the experimental jab was neither safe
nor effective the requirement for face
coverings was neither safe nor effective
uh the death rate you know or the
mortality rate of the code virus was
very very low it basically the same as a
common cold right but we stood on our
dots we wore the mass we took the
vaccinations and we did everything that
we were told to do didn't we but 70 of
the population did all that and there
was a small percentage of the population
that said no it's okay I'm fine I mean
I'll stay in my house I'll you know I'll
stand on your dots so I get my groceries
and I'll do those things but there's a
small percentage of the population that
doesn't want to comply with those things
so
yeah there's there's certainly something
going on out there isn't there
then you said the code in The Matrix
um do you subscribe to this that like
Andrew Tate says there's a matrix that's
controlling us do you subscribe to that
there's there's powers that be whether
you want to call it the Matrix I think
the Matrix is a more convenient term
because it's been popularized you know
since the movie with Keanu Reeves since
Andrew Tate got so popular so I think
the the the conversation around there's
things going on out there that you don't
see and that you don't control can be
easily distilled down to the Matrix
sure let's use that term I think that's
a convenient easy term for everybody to
understand
and do you think that's good or bad for
Humanity
depends do you want to conform and
comply and when the state says jump you
respond with how high are you happy with
eating bugs are you happy with having a
social credit score then you're gonna
say it's good for society but if you
value sovereignty if you Value
Independence if you value an ability to
maneuver if you value uh you know
control in your life then you're going
to say no
right I mean if you look at the way that
Society votes if you look at the way
that culture and most western uh
populations you know these these
demographics they're they're voting for
more of the control they're not voting
for more freedom and Independence and
sovereignty and ownership over their
lives right they're voting to invite the
state and the government in every aspect
of their life whenever possible and
again they're not doing it intentionally
they're not raising their hand and
saying right I want to get up in the
morning and have the government know
everything about me right it just it
just happens to be that they're falling
for those parties for the next election
and that's who they cast their vote for
some would say maybe they're not voting
you know there's a lot of arguments
between whether or not Biden or Trump
was the elected president of the United
States who cares but that's who they're
running with right now look who's Canada
you know who's Canada's prime minister
look who's running in the UK look who's
running in France you go all around the
Western countries and the same thing's
happening everywhere
so as an entrepreneur Rich have you
found it easier or harder in these times
to grow your business and make money
it's never been easier to grow a
business and make money than it is today
so don't listen to anybody that says oh
it's too hard there's only so much money
out there all the rich evil people have
taken it all and you know you'll never
get any because they're because they're
horrible there's money traveling through
the internet right now all you have to
do is do is offer some value and reach
out and grab some okay so that's true
but we live in a time where we have more
control than ever before right uh if you
live in the states or even in certain
places
um even in Canada you're going to find
that you can't you don't have the
freedom to run a business the way that
you would have run a business 40 50
years ago they keep adding new laws new
legislations there's new penalties
there's there's always something new
that they want to infuse into your
business life so
there's less
sovereignty there's less Independence
there's less control over your business
than what we had 50 years ago but on the
upside of it it's never been easier to
start a business because you don't need
to have a storefront you don't need
bricks and mortars all you need is an
internet connection and the ability to
offer value to people and you can do
that from literally anywhere in the
world
and if you evolved your business through
um this time you know maybe take us back
to how your business looked when you
started it and how it's evolved now
so in 20 so in 2003 I got a package in
the collection industry that I worked at
here in Canada I worked for Canada's
largest collection agency
uh that's where I learned that you get
hired for your resume but you get fired
because of fit in the in the corporation
so they let me go they gave me a few a
few dollars and they sent me home
that's when I started up uh totaled that
freedom which became Canada's largest
most successful debt settlement company
we've eliminated
over a quarter billion dollars of
consumer credit card debt so
to the point of
business it's it's very it's very easy
to get off the ground today
but you will find that as you grow the
business as you get more influences you
become known and as you have more impact
uh companies that oppose you or that
might see you as as competition will
start to do things to eliminate you or
to make it harder for you to run your
business with what I was doing we were
so successful at saving money for people
with their credit card debt and getting
them out of debt rapidly without the
damage of bankruptcy or an insolvency
they started to uh
essentially petition the uh the policy
makers this was the banks and the credit
card companies they started to petition
the policy makers to change the laws to
make it difficult to earn money or to
delay the first Revenue event so there's
a lot of complex things that uh happen
but it was it was a it was a great
opportunity and I'm glad I had the the
time in the business I've done the earn
out buyout now my brother runs it and I
essentially run a business today that's
a company of one so I can run this
business from anywhere in the world uh I
mostly sell information or or content
you know if you look at my YouTube
channel you know my books my podcast
stuff like that
um so I could essentially if I wanted to
I could get a sailboat and put a star
link on it and I could broadcast from
the middle of the Pacific Ocean on my
way to Fiji it's entirely possible that
you can do that today so I'm grateful
for those opportunities and it's you
know it's one of those things that
entrepreneurs have to be good at they
have to be good at problem solving and
getting these issues out of the way so
they can get to the goals
um I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out